last night after our backstage episode
wrapped which by the way you should go
to
dailywire.com or youtube after you're
done with this show to watch it
uh but only after you're done with this
show i logged on to twitter to discover
that i was trending
nationwide one thing i've learned over
the years is that when i trend it's
never because everyone is happy about
something i said i've never trended
because everyone is saying wow i agree
with
this point that matt walsh made i'm not
sure if anyone trends for that reason
but i certainly don't
for me it's always because people are
very mad very upset very outraged
about some opinion or some other opinion
that i expressed
that was certainly the case here in this
situation people
uh on the internet were were quite
apoplectic about
a tweet that i sent out in reaction to a
new gallup poll which showed that the
number of
kids and young adults who identify as
lgbt
has risen in an extraordinary and sudden
way
over the last few years is what i wrote
i said the number of kids who identify
as lgbt especially trans and bisexual
has absolutely skyrocketed if you think
this is a natural or organic development
you're deluded the media hollywood and
the school system
actively recruit children into the lgbt
ranks
i followed that up with this i said the
number of supposedly trans children and
young adults is 10 times higher than the
number among older generations
do you think that's because a lot more
people are born in the wrong body these
days whatever the hell that means
no this is social engineering in our
culture the lgbt lobby
poses the greatest threat to our
children especially the t part
so there it is the opinion that i have
been
uh that's the opinion that i've been
reliably informed by thousands of people
is detestable outrageous hateful bigoted
and so on
and much of the reaction was exceedingly
unhinged but none more so than the
response from parker malloy over at
media matters
who sent out a frantic string of tweets
implying
that i'm a pedophile for these opinions
on what basis were these accusations
made
well no basis of course it's just that
parker malloy
disagrees with me thus feels entitled to
make up
literally any lie at all in retribution
those tweets have all now been deleted
by the way
this is what we're dealing with from the
opposition people scummy enough to
defame and slander their ideological
opponents
but too cowardly to stand by the
defamation
most of the rest of the tweets and
messages i've received have been more
along the lines of you know calling me a
piece of garbage an idiot
a worthless sack of such and such i
should kill myself etc and so forth
so first of all after receiving all of
this feedback and seeing that my words
were so deeply hurtful to so many people
i want to say with all sincerity
that i am not sorry at all not even a
little bit
i couldn't be less sorry for what i said
i'm 100 right
everything i said was absolutely and
totally correct and i'm so happy that i
said it
i am not and could never be sorry for
being right i will
i will however happily accept the
apologies of any of my critics
should they decide to offer them i'm i'm
all ears for that i am a gracious and
forgiving man in that way
but as for being sorry myself not a
chance not ever
not ever i am though happy to explain
why i'm right
about what i said this is an important
issue by far one of the most important
issues that our culture faces in the
present moment
it's worth talking about in greater
detail so first let's go back and look
at the numbers okay
according to gallup the overall number
of americans who identify as lgbt is up
to 5.6 percent that's a one percent
increase from the last tally in 2017
that's a significant jump in just three
or four years
but the truly seismic shifts can be seen
among the youngest generations
among gen z and gallup defines that as
those born between 1997 and 2002
so this doesn't even take into account
the very youngest generations
where we can assume the figures are even
more dramatic
but among gen z a full 16 15.9 to be
exact
identify as lgbt another
five percent have apparently no opinion
about their own sexual orientation
breaking down the numbers further 2.1
percent of gen zeros say they're gay 1.4
say lesbian both of these figures
represent at least a doubling over gen x
and older generations
and then another another 11.5 percent
say they're bisexual
the number of trans people in gen z is
almost 2 1.8 percent right now
now that might seem like a small portion
but keep in mind that 1.8 percent is
nearly 10 times higher as i said in the
tweet
nearly 10 times higher than the portion
among
gen x and older generations and keep in
mind again
also that this does not take into
account those who are born
after 2002 and it's the after 2002
generation those who were born while i
was in high school
who've really been hit the hardest by
lgbt indoctrination
yes lgbt indoctrination
that is what's happening here and i
cannot take seriously
anyone who would deny it the drag queen
story hours
the trans books for kids the gender
theory propaganda shoved into kids minds
of the youngest ages
the constant promotion of lgbt
lifestyles and identities by school
hollywood the media and so on
all of this has two clear and purposeful
effects
number one it makes it seem trendy and
cool to be lgbt we've gone way beyond
mere acceptance or toleration
we have long since gone way beyond those
things
it is now for many young people seen as
more interesting more fashionable to be
able to tack a few letters from the
sacred initialism onto your name
you know years of associating being
cisgender and white with being
privileged
and being privileged with being an
oppressor and a bully has an
impact it turns out it's supposed to
have an impact
it is designed to have the very impact
that it's having
but if you point out that the strategies
are working you'll be called a bigot for
noticing that there's a strategy at all
so that's the first thing the second is
that kids are being taught
to view sex gender and sexual
orientation a certain way
they're being indoctrinated into a view
of sex and orientation
that when adopted by large numbers of
people will automatically and by design
increase the lgbt ranks for example
kids are being taught now that if you're
a boy with feminine tendencies
then you might actually be a girl if
you're a girl with masculine tendencies
you might actually be a boy kids are
taught that this is a
a possibility and encouraged to explore
that possibility
back when kids were not being taught
this kind of anti-scientific nonsense
a girl with masculine tendencies was
just a girl with masculine tendencies a
tomboy we might have called her
some girls were that way and that was
fine
some boys were more feminine and that
was fine too now
we're ushering those types of girls and
boys under the trans umbrella what we're
effectively saying is
you can't be that kind of girl or boy
anymore those don't exist anymore
because if you're a feminine boy then
you're a girl if you're a masculine girl
then you're a boy
why do you think there are now more
young people who call themselves
trans than call themselves lesbian
and there are almost as many and soon
will be more young people calling
themselves trans than gay
why is that because we've given young
people this new
framework for understanding themselves
the problem is that the framework is
totally false incoherent and based in
pseudoscience
so yes in effect
these children are being recruited to be
trans
they're being turned trans yes
that is what is happening kids are being
turned
trans they are being made
into something they are not this is
deliberate
it is diabolical it is damaging and
destroying many children
and i will not ever stop calling it what
it is no matter how loud the mob
screams or what labels they throw none
of that matters to me
what matters is the truth and this is it
hey listen hit the subscribe button do
it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated